beyrouth pensait avoir retrouvé depuis
quelques années la paix la douceur de
vivre et bien cet espoir a été brisée
aujourd'hui à la mi-journée une
explosion terrible quelques minutes plus
tard la mort de l'ancien premier
ministre rafic hariri était annoncé
gilles rabin 13 heures à beyrouth une
énorme explosion secoue le quartier des
grands hôtels
le front de mer tout juste reconstruit
et immédiatement transformée en champ de
bataille
sans la panique des passants tentent de
sortir les passagers des voitures en feu
avant d'en être empêché par l'intensité
des flammes qui atteignent parfois
plusieurs mètres de haut quand ils
parviennent encore à extraire une
victime de cette voiture officielle
l'escorté d'une 4-4-2 gardes du corps
ils comprennent que l'attentât visait
l'ancien premier ministre rafic hariri
qui m'ouvre à avant d'arriver à
l'hôpital
350 kg d'explosifs auraient été utilisés
dans cet attentat
une quantité énorme comme en témoigne le
cratère laissé par l'explosion
dans les immeubles alentours des pans de
murs entiers se sont effondrés des
dizaines de voitures ont été détruits
neuf personnes ont été tuées et plus
d'une centaine ont été blessés ou brûlés
bilan toujours très provisoire rafic
hariri ancien premier ministre est
milliardaire qui avait fait fortune en
arabie saoudite et l homme qui avait
reconstruit beyrouth après quinze ans de
guerre civile
il incarnait surtout la volonté
d'indépendance des libanais qui voulait
s'émanciper de la tutelle syrienne dans
un message diffusé par la télévision al
jazira le groupe pour la guerre sainte
au levant jusqu'ici inconnu a revendiqué
l'assassinât de rafic hariri
ce soir le liban tout entier est en état
de choc
dès la nouvelle connue les commerçants
ont fermé boutique à saïda la ville
natale de l'ancien premier ministre
des centaines d'habitants ampleur sont
descendus dans les rues tout ça qu'à
travers rafic hariri c'est le retour à
la démocratie et la paix au liban qui
sont visés